[Music]  reaching up towards the sky these three  thousand pillars stand tall from the  valley below to make a towering forest  of sandstone  [Music]  the zhang jiajie national forest park is  located in the west hunan province of  china and is over 600 miles away from  the major cities of shanghai and beijing  [Music]  fans of james cameron's avatar may find  these rock pillars familiar they were  the inspiration behind the mythical  world of pandora in the film  these pillars resulted from weather over  many years a combination of the changing  seasons and the plants that grow on them  have contributed to their individual and  unique shapes  although the seasons change the weather  is moist all year round which results in  dense foliage in fact 98 of the park is  covered in vegetation  there are hiking trails available to see  this incredible forest however as james  cameron knows nothing compares to  experiencing it from the sky  [Music]  [Music]  you